the turnout was interesting you had the
one of the number one issue in the
country is inflation uh now you do have
some change but it doesn't look like
there's going to be any policy changes
from the White House well I'm just glad
my Red Wave prediction is accurate
Florida how much time are we talking
about how much money
which adds to 1100 and the Thousand will
go to charity
oh many people see me as a charity case
so we'll see where that joke is if
you're saying you're receiving money to
the waters Foundation
no I'll pay up and uh give us your take
overall
so
the house is now in McCarthy's hands
Pelosi will probably go to Rome to be an
ambassador and that's fine and there'll
be investigations which is good
I was disappointed in the Senate outcome
because the polls showed it was going to
be 52-53. if you look at what happened
let's say in Pennsylvania I can't
believe
John Federman
I honestly can't believe they voted for
this guy so abortion was critical we
know in Pennsylvania I did not see that
it was going to be that critical Oz was
not a great candidate he had a brutal
primary he took the summer off and he
campaigned hard at the end but people
didn't trust them they didn't trust the
guy he wasn't from Pennsylvania and it
was fraudulent the way that fetterman
hid his condition and then skipped this
debate debated the last week by that
time they'd banked so many early votes
so Republicans really have to get a hold
of this early vote thing there's no
Republican early vote strategy
can anybody tell me what that is
Republicans vote on Election Day
Democrats vote for five weeks yep so
there's this Mass mobilization campaign
that's underway in these early voting
States and Republicans are sitting it
out you know they get souls to the polls
and Philly as they say they're knocking
on doors they're handing in ballots
there's paper everywhere what's the
Republican plan I don't know so they
need to plan for that Georgia I'm
nervous about because it looks like last
Salt's going to hold on to Nevada
Masters is cooked in Arizona
so it all is going to come down to
Georgia runoff again so we're this is
about Herschel Walker
and you know why yeah
who I like and they are admitting that
he did they crushed him on these
abortion attacks I mean this is going to
be another nail biter and it makes me
very nervous so you also have good races
run by Ron Johnson he's in there he's
going to investigate the hell out of the
Biden crime family Biden was very
against his election that's good but
there was never a shot apparently in New
Hampshire I mean that guy got railroaded
and if you put up a guy in in who's
running for governor in Pennsylvania who
just got slaughtered
I mean these things have down ballot
consequences that hurts Oz it hurts the
Republican house candidates zeldin did
great
considering this is a deep blue state
Kathy hokel had help from every Democrat
crooked Bill Obama Kamala everybody came
in to save her
and she barely held on but zeldin had
coattails and got a bunch of House
Republicans in there and it looks like a
bunch more House Republicans are going
to come in through the West Coast you
think this is going to be a nail butter
they're going to have the house it's not
going to be the biggest margin of all
time it's going to be bigger than they
say it is right now but this was a Red
Wave if you're looking at in Florida
Stacy's no longer with us she's going to
go back to writing erotic novels Abbott
won Beto bye bye find another office to
run there's just not the hatred for Joe
Biden that there is for Barack Obama and
for the clintons there's not a hate
Biden vote that's out there you know
when you go with Trump's on the ballot
there's that hate Trump Democrat vote
people just don't feel the same passion
against the guy that they also feel for
other people and we have a problem
demographically single women are voting
for Democrats by 30 points 37 37 points
in urban America they're cleaning our
clocks in the cities cleaning our clocks
I'm not saying anything nefarious is
going on but they are cleaning our
clocks in the cities and we're giving it
away
and the fact that these youth voters are
coming in so strong on an off year is
very concerning it looks like they've
been brainwashed this new generation is
totally brainwashed because a lot of
these single women are about 37 spreads
for Democrats are teaching all of our
younger generation in these schools and
they're polluting their minds and then
they grow up and then they're in their
20s and then they vote for leftists
where are we we are we are coming to you
for your reactions of anything I don't
know I I can't get wrapped up in this I
don't see what the problem is I didn't
need a red wave I implored people to be
realistic what you're seeing right here
is that Democrats are thrilled because
their expectations were disastrous and
the Republicans are a bit bummed because
their expectations were too high right
that's what you're seeing everybody got
a little pleased everybody got a little
disappointed so I'm I'm happy that
Republicans flip some seats I'm happy
about DeSantis I'm happy about that but
I'm burned about I'm bummed about vocal
I'm also happy that zeldin put crime
front and center that helped push New
York to the right you can't always get
what you want but you might get what you
need to quote air supply thank you yeah
and how I mean the fact is Jagger Jesus
anyway the point is this the only thing
that matters the only thing that matters
is the house and a win is a win it
doesn't have to be a red wave in the
house it could be a narrow wind but if
you want the investigations if you want
your hands on the purse strings you know
if you want National Greg Gutfeld day
you got to have the house got others the
Senate is less important although it
would have been cool but the thing is
this is what it is this is not the end
of democracy that's the funny thing
about this people were were we were
whipped up into a fervor that the
democracy was coming and blah blah
debate was ending and what it is is
people got people got disappointed they
got pleased it's not so bad now you got
to balance the power now you got you got
Biden in the White House you got the
Republicans on the purse strings that's
good there's also that the Democrats
spent a lot of time and money saying
that all these Republicans if they lost
they wouldn't accept the results yeah
that has not been true you know the
lesson for fetterman is that you know
what people care less about the actual
functioning of a candidate than whether
they can win and so those you could put
as Nancy Pelosi once said a glass of
water remember when AOC you can run a
glass of water it's going to win and
that's basically it Republicans have to
run perfect candidates yes they can run
water glasses well her shoulders better
they want me to play this sound or
they're going to fire me this is from
President Biden at the White House this
was his press conference this is what he
said about 2024 which is our next
election watch the Democratic party
outperformed anything anyone expected
and did better than any off-year
presidency since John Kennedy is one
that gives everybody like whoo
sigh relief that the mega Republicans
are not taking over the government again
Etc
and uh so uh
my judgment of running when I announce
if I die my intention is that I run
again but I'm a great respecter of fate
and this is ultimately a family decision
okay so what
I went for more
have gone on
a second term Joe Biden today is lucid
he's kind of upbeat he seems pretty
happy he's ready to roll again so that's
what came out of the midterms forget the
Red Wave the red tide whatever it was it
doesn't matter at this point Joe Biden
is running again and I got to say one
more thing the thing that disappoints me
is that you've got fetterman where
people are voting September 19th they
don't even see whether he's capable of
speaking until the 25th uh Katie Hobbs
will not debate Carrie Lake and she can
barely put a sentence together and she's
very close to Kerry Lake now although
who knows who's counting in Arizona I
mean I don't know if I'm not going to
say it if people who can't read or are
counting and then the other thing is Joe
Biden was in the basement he didn't come
out so the more you hide the more you
don't debate the more you delay you're
going to win it doesn't matter on your
side if you're a Democrat yeah that's
why I agree do you want to talk about
bite in 2024 for a moment well it looks
like he's going to run after he talks it
over with Jill and
it looks like Trump is going to run
because he's going to announce next week
so it looks like it's a rematch and in
this environment it looks tough for
Donald Trump if you look at what
happened last night some of his
candidates did not do well and
I think a lot of people are thinking you
know he put together this massive war
chest didn't spend the kind of money
that a lot of people had hoped he'd
spend and you know it's going to bring
out the crazies on the left I mean I I
love Trump I want him to run I think
he's a great candidate I loved him as
president he brings out such Insanity on
the left they will walk over hot coals
to vote against Donald Trump but then
you have Joe Biden it was just like this
like guy he's like falling asleep up
there he doesn't Inspire the passion
from the right that you'd expect I mean
I can't stand the guy I think he's
destroying the country on the border on
the dollar everything but when we're
Democrats and we're expected came out to
vote right and that is abortion that is
an incredible amount of funding they
threw out of those candidates let me go
to Greg and get Jesse that's a terrible
yeah at the last minute because one of
the things that would be different if
Joe Biden runs this time is that kovid
we hope won't be back and he would have
to be out on the campaign Trail no they
find another no that there'd be another
uh another strain of covid you had to be
coveted 2023 and when that ended up
he'll be in her medically sealed
probably in a sarcophagus yes how's that
for a word how's that for a word I don't
know I I don't buy any of this two years
that's a long time we've watched him
degrade over periods of months and then
he comes back and he's lucid and he's
not and I'm also it's two years is a
long time for the Republicans to you
know we talk about Trump trump
I gave him 80 that he's gonna run but I
also but I also think that DeSantis I
mean DeSantis is right now the guy
that's his his he's a different rival
than the others because he's just he's a
he's a strong governor who just whipped
Charlie Crist right but he could get
destroyed in a primary with Trump
brutalized annihilated how so verbally
yeah but does that one I think if you
look at the voters the voters in these
primary states in the south in in
critical Battleground States will vote
for Trump over Ron DeSantis no question
okay what about the Democrats are they
comfortable with Joe Biden running in
2024
based on last night's results I would
say yes overall but what was really
exciting to me is that you actually saw
and I get asked this a lot where's your
bench well my bench the Democrats bench
was winning all over the country
Gretchen Whitmer we're going to talk
about what happened in Florida in a
couple blocks
what I mean she did win but she won by
the same margins as Ron DeSantis Josh
Shapiro no she didn't no she didn't
eight points right yeah
sorry higher yeah okay I take it back
okay it's not like Camp it was about
like I was sorry then I'll take my bet
back let's go
sorry uh Josh Shapiro who is an
incredible candidate out of Pennsylvania
Jared Polis in Colorado and Tim Ryan who
lost but really showed people a path of
how you can campaign in a state like
Ohio and he's not obviously shared Brown
is special on another level and these
people are are going to be around and
they're very appealing well you say good
I think that you saw it last night as
well there were a pretty impressive
bunch of young Republicans who won as
well yes and you haven't really heard
their names yet but you will get to know
them uh some of them will the first you
know that we've had some good diversity
of for example the amount the number of
women that have won there was also the
One race down on the border that was
able to be won by one of the Latina
candidates Kevin McCarthy had recruited
so there are there are some bright spots
and some younger people that are running
on both sides and that is not a bad
thing if you're trying to build a bench